الذي يقوم برحلة ميدانية - عرض وتحدث
للسلك الدبلوماسي والصحفي في بيروت بقيادة
وزير الخارجية اللبناني جبران
فاسيلي - بهدف دحض مزاعم
رئيس الوزراء الإسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو الأسبوع الماضي بأن حزب الله
بصحة إيران يجهز جميع الصواريخ
بأنظمة توجيه متطورة
على حافة العاصمة اللبنانية ، لقد
وضعوا ثلاثة من مواقع تحويل الصواريخ هذه
على طول
مطار بيروت الدولي ، إليكم
صورة تساوي ألف صاروخ
هنا مطار بيروت الدولي هذا
الخطاب المنبه ووزير الخارجية اللبناني ،
لذلك أشعر بالقلق لأن هذه
المرة فقط تثبت مرة واحدة  أكثر من أن نتنياهو
يستعد لعدوان آخر على
بلدي ، ذهبنا إلى موقعين من المواقع الثلاثة
، جولة فوضوية متسرعة تركت
السفير اليوناني
يمسك قشة الحقيقة ولكن حتى الآن هل
رأيت أي شيء يجعلك أكثر حكمة ،
لا أنا.  لقد كنت في ملعب الجولف ، حيث
أزال الروس طائرات نتنياهو ،
فليس من المنطقي
أن يقول إنه يشتبه في ذلك.  أقر بهذا نعم ، لا ،
قد يكون لدى الدبلوماسيين الأمريكيين الذين يحضرون حزب الله صواريخ دقيقة أو لا يمتلكونها بالقرب من
المطار بصواريخ دقيقة
في آذار / مارس بمناسبة العيد
الإسلامي لقصر الشهر الماضي ، أعلن
الأمين العام لحزب الله ، حسن نصر الله ،
أن المقاومة تتمتع الآن
بالدقة وعدم الدقة  الصواريخ
وقدرات الأسلحة التي إذا
فرضت إسرائيل حربًا على لبنان ستواجه
مصيرًا وواقعًا لم
تتوقعه أبدًا بعد الكثير من الاندفاع
والاندفاع والتعرق ، ويبقى الوضوح بعيد المنال
خلال هذا النوع من الجولات ، ومن
الصعب جدًا إما إثبات أو
دحض مزاعم  رئيس الوزراء الإسرائيلي
الذي كنا نركض فيه رأينا
ملعبًا للجولف وملعبًا لكرة القدم
ومسبحًا ومستودعًا ولكن ليس هناك
الوقت أو القدرة على معرفة
ما ننظر إليه حقًا في بن ويدمان CNN
Beirut